i had the administration after me for
selling homecoming teacher to my senior
year of college so back in college me
and my friends decided to make
homecoming t-shirts and at this point
we'd sold about 300 t-shirts maybe at 50
left and we were selling them all over
campus but this day we decided to go to
a school bonfire and see if we could
sell some there so at the bonfire this
lady comes up to me who i have never
seen in my life and she tells me that we
can't be selling the t-shirts because of
a trademark issue we'd been using the
same logo but if you look closely the
bluej on the logo is just a generic
bluej it's not our trademarked school
logo so then she tries to tell us that
we can't use the elmhurst on the
t-shirts but if you look closely it
doesn't say our college name anywhere on
the t-shirt just the town that we lived
in so then the woman tells us that
they're getting complaints all over
school from the writing on the back of
the t-shirt and she started saying
really absurd things like we were
promoting sexual assault like for part
two